[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في اخبار الساعه من
العربيه
برصاص قرب بيروت
السلطه الايرانيه
[تصفيق]
والله معناته الاوروبيه تعلن الدعم
المحتجين الايرانيين المعرضين للاعدام
ومطالبات بمعاقبه النظام
واشنطن تخطط الارسال معدات الكترونيه
متطوره لاوكرانيا وضغط روسي لعدم التحقيق
في مسيره
البريطانيه تقول ان رئيس الوزراء
ريشيسونات يخطط لفرد قوانين ليبكافحه
الاضطرابات
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا البدايه من الاخبار
التي وردت قبل قليل حيث قالت قوه
الدفاعلانديه في بيان ايرلندي
قافله تقل ثمانيه جنود كانت متجهه صوب
بيروت اسلحه خفيفه
انها فتحت تحقيقا بالتنسيق مع قوه
اللبنانيه بشان مقتل جنديه
الى ايران والاحتجاجات المستمره اذا تواصل
شرطه الايرانيه استخدام الاعدام كوسيله
لترهيب هدف قمع حركه الاحتجاجات حيث كانت
منظمه حقوق الانسان
على الاعتراف بصنع زجاجات حارقه وكتابه
شعاراته
وفي ملف يعتقالات ايران التعسفيه لا تزال
ردود الفعل الدوريه المندد تتواولى حيث
اعلنت عضوتان في البرلماني الالماني عن
تبنيهما الكفاله السياسيه للمحتجه شايان
جاراني الذي اتهمته ايران بالافساد في
الارض والمحتج المراهقه ايضا سوريا شريفي
البالغه من العمر 16 عاما فقط المحبوسين
في السجون الايرانيه والذين يواجهان خطر
الاعدام فيما اعلنت النائبه عن استقحان في
البرلمان السويدي
وكاله سياسيه المعار للمعارضه الايرانيه
فارزنا قره المحكوم عليها بالسجن لمده
خمسه 25
في
الاتحاد الاوروبي
ايران لا تزال تلوح بالتهديد والوعيد لقمع
الناشطين بحجه تورطهم باعمال شغب خلال
الاحتجاجات فيما يقولوا وزير مخابراتها
اسماعيل خطيب للنشاطاء في الخارج ان ايران
ستلاحقكم وتنزل بكم العقاب
سيعاقب كل من اضر بالبلاد اينما كان في
العالم وكل شخص متورط في اعمال الشغب
سيعاقب ايضا
تهديدات النظام تاتي بالتزامن مع ذكر
الثالثه لاعتقال الناشط والصحفي الايراني
روح الله زم وايضا بعد تهديدات الحرس
الثوري ضد صحفي ايران انترناشونال التي
اعلنت في الشهر الماضي عن تهديدات موثوقه
تلقاها صحفيوها من الحرس الثوري لكن ما هي
الوسائل التي تمكن الاستخبارات الايرانيه
من الوصول الى خصومها في الخارج لدى ايران
شبكاته تجسس وازرع في دول المجاوره بينها
تركيا والعراق
في فرنسا عام 2019 ايضا اختطف النظام
الايراني خلال السنوات الاخيره نشطاء
بينهما جمشيد شارما هاد وفرج الله كعب
المعروف بحبيب اسيا ود وايضا اختطاف مدير
مجموعه تندر الناشط شارما هاد ذو 66 عاما
من قبل عملاء ايرانيين خلال رحلته من
المانيا الى الهند في 2020 في المقابل
اخفقت بعده عمليات الاختطاف بينها خليه
اسطنبول حين اعلنت تركيا عن اعتقال اشخاص
مرتبطين بعمليه اختطاف النشره حبيب فيما
القى جهاز المخابرات التركيه القبض على 11
شخصا من اعضاء شبكه تهريب المخدرات
التابعه لناجي شريف في زان دشتي متورطين
ايضا في اختطاف اسيا بالاضافه الى
الاشتباه في قيام اعضاء الشبكه بعمليات
تجسس لصالح الحرس الثوري ومع استمرار
ملاحقه معارضيه الخارج طبقا معضله
الاساسيه
قاعه الايرانيه هي احتجاجات الداخل التي
لم تخمد في شهر الثالث
من لندن مشاهدينا ينضم الينا عرف نصر
الباحث في الشان الايراني اهلا بك سيد
عارف معنا في هذه النشره اذا هذا التعاطف
والدعم الاوروبي للمحتجين وخاصه للمعتقلين
والمعرضين لخطر الاعدام في ايران هل يخدم
قضيتها هؤلاء المعتقلين ام يزيدها تعقيدا
وكيف يضوي اليه النظام ايضا
تحيه طيبه
الكرام الوضع نحن نعلم بان بالاتكال همم
ليست همم يعني حاله قانونيه صح التعبير
ممكن ان تفيده هؤلاء بشكل قانوني انما هي
ممكن همم اعتبارها عمليه اعلاميه اكثر
بمعنى انها تستطيع ان تفيده هؤلاء من خلال
طرحهم بالاعلام كضيه ضغط جانبيه اضافه الى
ان ممكن ان تؤدي الى ضغط من خلال الحكومات
الاوروبيه من هنا انا اعتقد بان هذا الامر
هو بدايه تحركات اكبر او على الاقل بانه
ممكن ان نعتبره خطوه الى الامام بمواجهه
الهم علي الايرانيه مثل هذه الخطوات لم
تكن بالسابق همم اما الجانب الاخر انا
اعتقد بان الجانب الايراني يقرا هذه
التحركات على انها خطيره جدا لانه يعلم
بان ازدياد وتيره العقوبات بامكانها ان
تميد كثير من الملفات العالقه بين الجانب
الاوروبي والجانب الايراني طيب يعني
الضغوط الدوليه والاوروبيه متزايده بشكل
كبير ااه الكره الثالثه تتدحرج ايضا همم
كيف يمكن النظام ان يخرج نفسه من هذه
الازمه
الواقع بان الطرق او ربما الاستداريوهات
التي امام النظام محدوده جدا خاصه وان
هناك خلافها سياسيه داخليه حتى بين التيار
الاصولي اضافه الى ان ربما ادخال الجيش
والقوات الحرس الثوري بشكل مباشر ممكن ان
يؤدي الى ما لا يحمد عقباه الى النظام
الايراني وخاصه وان المرشد الايراني لا
يريد ان يتورط بشكل شخصي بغمع هذه
الاحتجاجات ونحن نعرف طبيعته بانه عاده
متحفظ بان يتحمل اي مسؤوليه لكن ماذا
اخذنا بعين الاعتبار اسلوب الاعدامات سواء
بجغرافيا الاعدامات او الفئه العمريه يعني
كانت تعمل الموجهه الى هؤلاء فيما يبدو
بان الاعتماد على همم
تهمه الحرابه هي الا الطرق ضررا الى
النظام الايراني خاصه وان القانون
الايراني او قانون عقوبات الاسلاميه في
ايران يحمل الغاضي حصرا اختيار السقف الذي
من خلاله يستطيع ان يصدر الحكومه بالتالي
حتى اذا كانت هنالك اعدامات كبيره القاضي
هو المسؤول وليس السلطه القضائيه
التي يستمر بها هؤلاء المحتجين لاكثر من
ثلاثه اشهر حتى الان رغم اله القمع
الايرانيه من اين يستمدون عزيمتهم واصارهم
على مقاومه هذا النظام
الواقع عدم التجاوب النظام الايراني مع
الاحتجاجات مع اقل المطالب او حتى التعامل
معهم باعتبارهم مواطنين هو همم يؤدي الى
همم الى ازدياد هذه الوتيره خاصه ونحن
نعلم بان اي رجوع من قبل متظاهرين يعني
همم ربما تعزيز درجه كبيره من القمع
وعمليه انتقاميه من قبل النظام الايراني
لذلك يعني كما هو معروف بعالم السياسه ما
يعمل نصف ثوره كما يحفر غبره بنفسه الشعب
المدرك هذه الحقيقه وبالتالي لا اعتقد
بانه يا ترى شكرا لكم
الايراني تحياتي
شكرا
الامريكيه الاتفاقيني يعزز من نفوذه في
الملف الايراني باجماع كل من حزب بين
الديمقراطي والجمهوري حيث توافق المشرعون
على مشروع قانون يلزم الاداره بتاسيس
مجموعه عمل متخصصه لنظر في برنامج ايران
النووي على ان تقدم هذه المجموعه تقريرا
مفصرا للكونغرس كل 4 اشهر يتضمنوا معلومات
دقيقه عن برنامج تخصيب اليورانيوم وتخزين
المواد النوويه والتسلح وبرنامج الصواريخ
ويطلب المشروع من الاداره الامريكيه تقديم
استراتيجيه سنويا
لمواجهه انشطه ايران النوويه والصاروخيه
وتم ادراج المشروع في موازنه الدفاع للعام
المقبل التي سيقرها الكونغرس هذا الاسبوع
ما يضمن الموافقه عليه بشكل حاسم
في ايران ايضا مشاهدينا قضت السلطات
الايرانيه بسجن عامل الاغاثه البلجيكي
اوليف ايفان دي كاستل لمده ثمانيه وعشرين
عاما في الوقت الذي تشدد فيه عائلته
والسلطه البلجيكيه على براءته وانه محتجز
كراهينه في اطار جهود طيران للضغط من اجل
اطلاق سراح الدبلوماسي الايراني اسد الله
اسدي
الاجانب ومزدوج الجنسيه من ذوي الاصول
الايرانيه حولهم النظام في طهران الى ورقه
ابتزاز تلوح بها امام الحكومات الاجنبيه
اخر هذه الاوراق حكم اصدرته السلطات
الايرانيه يقضي بسجن عامل الاغاثه
البلجيكي اولمبيه لمده 28 عاما بعد
اعتقاله في فبراير الماضي بتهم التجسس وهي
الاتهامات التي تنفيها السلطات البلجيكيه
وعائله المدان بقوه بلجيكا ترى في قضيه
عامر الاغاثه والحكم الصادر في حقه وسيله
ضغط ايرانيه على بلجيكا لاطلاق صلاح
الدبلوماسيه الايراني اسد الله اسد
المحكوم ب 20 سنه بالسجن في بلجيكا على
خلفيه ادانته بالتخطيط لهجوم على تجمع
للمعارضه الايرانيه في فرنسا عام 2018
خطوه ايرانيه تاتي بعد اسبوع من تعليق
المحكمه الدستوريه في بلجيكا معاهده
لتبادل السجناء مع ايران والتي انتظروا ان
يصدر الحكم النهائي في مدى شرعيتها خلال
ثلاثه اشهر معتبره محللون انه رد غاضب من
ايران بعد هذا التعليق وان كان مؤقتا
اعلنت بحريه لحرس الثوري الايراني صباح
اليوم الخميس عن ايقافها سفينه قالت انها
تحمل وقودا وهربا في مياه الخليج وذلك
بحسب ما ذكرت قناه العالم الايراني والتي
تحدثت ايضا عن اعتقال الحرس الثوري اثني
عشر من افراد طاقم السفينه تحدث المرصد
السوري مشاهدينا عن سماع دوي انفجارات
بمدينه الميادين الخاضعه لسيطره فصائل
ايرانيه في شرق سوريا وذلك بالتزامن مع
تحقيق طائره مجهوله في اجواء المنطقه وكان
المرصد ذكر في وقت سابق ان هناك انفجارات
اخرى في محيط حقل العمر اكبر القواعد
العسكريه في سوريا
مستمره مشاهدينا وفيها بعد الفاصل القيمه
الاوروبيه تنطلق اليوم وتطورات حرب
اوكرانيه والازمه ايرانيه على الطاوله
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا من جديد يبحث قاده
الاتحاد الاوروبي في اجتماعي في بروكسل
اليوم تطورات حرب اوكرانيا والازمه
الايرانيه وازمه ارتفاع اسعار الطاقه
ومخاطر دخول الاتحاد
العام المقبل بدوره قال رئيس المجلس
الاوروبي
على جميع الاصدقاء
العسكريه الروسيه لدرجه عاليه من الدقه
كما تشتمل هذه المعدات على اجهزه تحديد
المواقع بدقه عاليه ويمكن تثبيتها على
مجموعه متنوعه من الاسلحه ما يوفر ما يعرف
بداخيره الهجوم المباشر المشترك التقنيه
مشاهدينا يستخدمها الجيش الامريكي في
القنابل التي يصل وزنها الى الفيرسل ويتم
دمجها مع الطائرات القديفه والطائرات
المقاتله وذلك بحسب صحيفه واشنطن بوستن
دبلوماسيان غربيان ان روسيا ما رستوطا
كبيره الامين المتحده
لعدم فتح تحقيق بخصوص ارسال ايران طائرات
مسيره موسكو لاستخدامها في حرب اوكرانيا
حسب ما ذكره
وفقا لدماسيين او لدبلوماسيين الغربي
الامم المتحده ووكيله الشؤون السياسيه
مصممه على تفويض بتكليف خبراء خبراء لبحث
امر ارسال الطائرات المسير الى روسيا
واشار الى وجود ثوابقه من حالات الممثله
في الشرق الاوسط
مشاهدينا الضوء
معنا في هذه النشره يبدو اذا ان واشنطن
ماضيه بجديه في التسليح اوكرانيا وتنتقل
من مرحله الى مرحله من مرحله الاسلحه
النوعيه الى مرحله الاسلحه الذكيه الا يعد
ذلك بمثابه انخراط اعمق لواشنطن في هذا
النزاع الدائر بين روسيا واوكرانيا
تجيبه
[موسيقى]
حده التوتر
وحرب الروشه لم تتوقف هذا الهجوم الروسي
لم تتوقف في اوكرانيا بغض النظر اي تطبيق
خصوصا بعد الاجتماع
قائد القوات المسلحه وغيره
في هذا المجال لا يعطي
افضل روايه
احد الامريكي
يدفع بالتساؤل يعني اذا ما كانت هناك خطوط
حمراء او كان هناك سقف تحرص واشنطن على
عدم تجاوزه في اطار هذا النزاع بين روسيا
واوكرانيا كما اشهرناه
هناك اي امكانيه
عندما تتخذ مثل هذا القرارات لانا ذكرته
دليل اما هي فقدت
لي يشعر
العلاقات الدوليه علاقات مع الروسي لا
يمكن ان يتبنى في المستقبل على هذه
المباني
العلاقات دبلوماسيه امريكا حتى
وظائف
التعاون امريكي
اسود ما ممكن بسبب طلب الامريكي
المباشره في الصراع والخارج الروسيه تقول
ان جميع الاسلحه المقدمه من الغرب لك هي
هدف مشروع لنا هل همم
منظومه مثلا لم تتعرض من قبل الاستهداف
لكن هل يمكن للمواسطه ان تستهدفها فعلا
ولا يمكن هل يمكن ان يعرض ذلك هذه الازمه
بشكل اكبر الى مواجهه اكبر بين همم موسكو
واشنطن باختصار لو تكرمت
اليوم عن امكانيه استعمال السلاح
القنابل الذي كانت يستعمل همم امريكا في
بغداد
[موسيقى]
عندنا يتحدثون عن امكانيه الاستعمال تلك
السلع ويمكن نقوله انها بفعاليه لا اقل من
همم
انفعال همم قنبله النوويه نعم ولكن
نعم هذا الوقت شكرا حياتي
شكرا
ذكر صحيفه الدليل ان رئيس الوزراء
البريطاني يخطط لفرد قوانين لمكافحه
الاضرابات وفي مقابله مع الصحيفه خالص
لكثير من الناس خاصه في وقت عيد الميلاد
مضيفا انه على استعداد لفرد تشريع جديد
العمل المقبل لحمايه حياه الناس وتقليل
الاضطراب بينما تستمر اضرابات وعمال
ويتوقع ان يبدا اضراب الممرضين في القطاع
الصحي الاربعاء القادم
محكمه التركيه بسجن رئيس بلديه اسطنبول
المعارضه الذي يحظى بشعبيه واسعه اكرام
محكمه العليا
اعد ميدان السياسه في تركيا الى التوتر
مجددا بعد قرار محكمه تركيه بسجن رئيس
بلديه اسطنبول المعارضه اكرم امام اوغلو
لمده سنتين و سبعه اشهر و 15 يوما اضافه
لحرمانه من العمل السياسي قبل اشهر قليله
فقط من انتخابات الرئاسيه وبرلمانيه حاسمه
امام اوغلو عضو حزب الشعب الجمهوري اكبر
احزاب المعارضه اودين بتهمه اهانه اعضاء
المجلس الاعلى للانتخابات بينما اكد
محاميه انه سيستانف القرار الذي لم يعتبر
نافذا قبل مصادقه محكمه الاستئناف
والمحكمه العليا
متابعه هذه المحكمه هذه القضيه دليل على
عدم وجود عداله في تركيا هذه القضيه
يقودها اشخاص لا يريدون تحقيق اسم القيم
مثل العداله والديمقراطيه للبلاد
قالت احزاب المعارضه والعديد من النقابات
والمنظمات المهنيه رفضوا قرار المحكمه
وتضامن مع امام موكلو
اولا هذه ليست دعوه حقيقيه بل سياسيه
ثانيا هذه القضيه غير متوازنه ثالثا هذه
القضيه هي التقنيه من انتخابات اسطنبول
التي لم يستطيع ان يفوز بها مرتين
سجن رؤساء البلديه ومسؤولين من هذه
الاحزاب والان يطبقون هذا الشيء مع امام
رئاسه بلديه اسطنبول اعتبر اكرم امام
اوغلو ان اولئك الذين الغوا فوزه في
الانتخابات اغبياء مرددا عباره استخدامها
وزير الداخليه سليمان سولو ضده قبل بضع
ساعات من هذا التصريح الذي عرض رئيس بلديه
اسطنبول للملاحقه القضائيه بتهمه اهانه
مسؤولين حكومين لا شك ان عمليات التحضير
للانتخابات لن تكون كما كانت عليه قبل
قرار المحكمه بحق اكرم امام اوغلو والواضح
ان المعارضه ستستغل القرار بشكل كبير
حملاتها الانتخابيه خصوصا بين انصار حزب
العداله والتنميه الحاكم الذين صوت شطر
منهم لامام اوغلو في الانتخابات البلديه
الماضيه زيدان زينجو العربيه اسطنبول
نشاطنا مستمره مشاهدينا وفيها بعد الفاصل
رئيس البصي عبد الفتاح السيسي يطلب من
واشنطن الضغط للتواصل الى اتفاق بشان سد
النقطه
الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه الافريقيه تحدث الرئيس السيسي
مع وزير الخارج امريكي حول حيويه موضوع سد
النهضه بالنسبه لمصر مؤكدا على ضروره
التواصل اتفاق للمعايير الدوليه من جهه
اخرى اكدت الخارجيه الامريكيه في بيان ان
بلانكن ايضا شدد على اهميه التوصل الاتفاق
الدبلوماسي لحمايه حقوق جميع الاطراف
[موسيقى]
هكذا رئيس مجلس السياده السوداني عبد
الفتاح البرهان عدم وجود اي تسويه مع
الفراق السياسيين بل ان ما جرى هو اتفاق
حول نقاط يمكن ان تساعد على حاله السياسيه
في البلاد وتشكيل حكومه جديده محذرا من
المساسب الجيش
في اتفاق جوني جابر
نشوف انه هذه النقاط او هذه الامور
الامان
لكن اذا كان في حاجه بتمس الجيش وبتمس
القوات المسلحه
عشان السودانيين ووقعناه السودان كله عشان
احنا مشينا الامام بنساعد لانه نعيد بلدنا
الى مسار الطبيعي
دعت الامم المتحده المجتمع الدولي لتوفير
نحو بل نحو مليارين دولار كمساعده
الانسانيه عاجله لقرابه 13 مليون شخص في
مناطق مختلفه من السودان تضررات بنزاعات
او الكوارث الطبيعيه
تهدد حياه ملايين السودانيين فالازمه
السياسيه والنزاعات المسلحه والكوارث
الطبيعيه وتفشي الامراض وتراجع الانتاج
الزراعي كلها عوامل اجتمعت معا لتشكل
تحديا غير مسبوق للسلطات الانتقاليه
تحديات تفوق قدره السلطات التي تناشد
المجتمع الدولي
تتعلق
بمعالجات
الثانيه
تحولات كثيره سياسيه واقتصاديه همم
محليه اقليميه دوليه الامم المتحده قدرت
حاجتها الى مليار و 700 مليون دولار بشكل
عاجل لتتمكن من تقديم المساعدات الانسانيه
لملايين المحتاجين في السودان
لاكثر من 12 مليون و500,000 شخص لانهم في
حاجه ملحه للطعام و مياه الشرب وخدمات
الصرف الصحي والماوى والتعليم والحمايه
وكل انواع المساعدات من بين هؤلاء 12
مليون هناك اكثر من ثلاثه ملايين نازح في
مناطق النزاعات المسلحه خاصه في اقليم
دارفور والنيل الازرق معظمهم من النساء
والاطفال
انس نماسي العربيه
انطلقت عمليه الاقتراع للاستحقاق
البرلماني في الدوائر الانتخابيه خارج
التونسي تزامنا مع ختام الدعايه
الانتخابيه للمترشحين داخل لها وهذا
الاقتراح سيتواصل طيله ثلاثه ايام في ثلاث
دوائر انتخابيه فقط بعد تعليق الهيئه
العليا المستقله للانتخابات للمسائل
الانتخابي في سبع دوائر اخرى بسبب عدم
وجود مترشحين معلنه عن شغل المقاعد
الشاغره بمجلس النواب في فتره لاحقه ووفقا
لقانون الانتخابي الجديد الذي اصدره
الرئيس التونسي سعيد ضمير المترشحون
الثلاثه مقاعدهم في البرلماني
ومن تونس مشاهدينا تنضم الينا الصحافيين
حمداوي اهلا بك يا نسرين وكيف تسير اذن
عمليه الاختراع في الدوائر الانتخابيه
الثلاث
ه
التشريعيه 2018 في ثلاث دوائر بالخارج وهي
فرنسا اثنين وفرنسا 3 دائره ايطاليا
باعتبار ان بقيه الدوائر الانتخابيه
بالخارج وعددها 7 لن تشهد فتح لمكاتب
الاقترا باعتبار انه لم يترشح احد الى
حدود هذه اللحظه الهيئه العليا للانتخابات
تقول انه تم فتح مكاتب الاختراع في موعدها
المحدده دون تسجيل اي تاخير دون تسجيل اي
اخلالات من اي نوع اخر اما في الداخل فانه
اليوم هو اليوم الاخير في فتره الحمله
الانتخابيه على ان ندخل غدا في فتره الصمت
الانتخابي قبل التوجه الى مكاتب الاقتراع
في كل الولايات الجمهوريه بدايه من الساعه
الثامنه صباحا بالتوقيت المحلي بتونس يوم
السبت 17 من ديسمبر مع بعض التغييرات في
مواقيت
اقتراع ذلك اما لاسباب امنيه في الاماكن
الحدوديه في تونس وايضا لاسباب دينيه اخرى
باعتبار ان هناك يقتل فيها
خاص من من الديانه اليهوديه ومن المنتظر
ان يتم غلق مكاتب الاقتراع على الساعه
8:00 مساء عوضا عن الساعه السادسه نعم
فيما يتعلق بالنقطه التي اثرتها نسرين حول
عدم وجود مترشحين في الدوائر الانتخابيه
التي علقت فيها العمليه الانتخابيه همم من
قبل الهيئه العامه للانتخابات هل او
الهيئه المستقله للانتخابات ما الذي يقوله
المراقب حول ذلك ما هي الاسباب هل يعود
ذلك للمقاطعه طيب همم يبدو اننا فقدنا اذا
نتواصل معها الزميله نسرين الحمداوي سنعود
اليك مره اخرى هذه نشره المقبله علامه
الولايات المتحده انها ستقدم 150 مليون
دولار لتزويدي مستشفيات في افريقيا جنوب
الصحراء الكبرى بالكهرباء وقالت الوكاله
الامريكيه للتنميه الدوليه الى المبادره
خمس سنوات وتحديث الى توفير الكهرباء
وتسهيل الوصول الى الانترنت الى اكثر من
10,000 مشاهده صحيه في جميع انحاء افريقيا
جنوب الكبرى مشيره الى ان البرنامج سيركز
على الطاقات المتجدده بهدف مكافحه التغير
المناخي
اعلن المجلس الرئاسي الليبي برئاسه محمد
المنيفي انه احال شكوى مقدمه من عائله
المواطن بعجيله مسعود المريمي الى النائب
العام الليبي وطلبه باتحاد الاجراءات
اللازمه وذكره التلفزيون ليبيا الاحرار ان
المجلس طالب وزاره العدل في حكومه الوحده
بالتنسيق مع الخارجي لتعيين هيئه دفاع عن
المريم ومتابعه الامر مع سلطات الامريكيه
كما طالب المجلس الرئيس
يتجه الاردن مشاهدينا الى الاعتماد على
الطاقه المتجدده لتوليد الطاقه في ظل
ارتفاع اسعار الكهرباء والمشتقات النفطيه
حيث تساهم الطاقه الشمسيه والطاقه الرياح
في انتاج ما يقارب 29 في المئه من الطاقه
المولده في الاردن
كيلو بالاتجاه للطاقه البديله لم يكن وليد
اللحظه عند السيد اديب منذ اكثر من 12
عاما اتجه الى طاقه الشمس لتوليد الكهرباء
واليوم يعتمد السيد اديب على الطاقه
النظيفه في استخداماته 100% متجاوزا ازمه
ارتفاع اسعار الكهرباء
خلال ثلاث سنوات همم هذول طبعا انا
استخدام عالي بيت كبير ومع الاسوار ومع
البوابات ومع استخدام ومعتمد على الكهرباء
احنا وفرنا بما يقارن حوالي 20.000 دينار
خلال الثلاث سنوات الماضي
الاردن على طاقه الشمس والرياح بما يقارب
29% من الطاقه المولده ظروف الاقتصاديه
والسياسيه تدفع الولاده لضروره استغلال
الموارد الطبيعيه المتجدده لتخفيف
استيرادها من الخارج فهنا واحد من اكبر
المجمعات الشمسيه في المنطقه
اضافه لمشروع طاقه الرياح في دوله تسعى
الاعتماد طاقه البديله بدعمها تكلفه انظمه
الخلايا الشمسيه للقطاع المنزلي والسياحي
والصناعي بنسبه تصل الى خمسينات
هدفنه هو احدى همم اثر اقتصادي واجتماعي
مباشر على المواطنين ومساعدتهم على تحمل
فاتوره الكهرباء الشهريه ورغم الحاجه
الملحه لرفع قدره الشبكات والخطوط المولده
للطاقه الشمسيه الا ان طبيعه الاردن
الجغرافيه المناسبه لمشاريع الطاقه
النظيفه اضافه لكونه واحدا من دول الحزام
الشمسيه كانت دافعه لاستغلال موارده غير
المكلفه وسط ازمه عالميه ضاعفت من قيمه
فاتوره الكهرباء
سوها جميل العربيه عمان
هذه الاخبار العاجله نقله عن ابنتي شقيقه
خامل الى العربيه تقول عند وفاه خامل
النظام سيسقط وتقول ايضا ان ابي قتل بسبب
معارضته للنظام بالعوده الى سياق نشاطنا
ركود المياه والجفاف الذي تشهده محافظه
النجف الواقعه في الجنوب الغربي للعاصمه
العراقيه بغداد تسبب في انتشار الامراض
الفتاكه التي ساهمت في انخفاض الانتاج
السمكه وتراجع واحده من اكثر المهن عراقه
في البلاد نشاهد التفاصيل
منذ سنوات والعراق يعاني من انخفاض متواصل
في الارادات المائيه عبر نهر دجله والفرات
وتحديدا في محافظه النجف الواقعه في
الجنوب الغربي للعاصمه بغداد
المحافظه التي كانت تعرف لدى الجميع بانها
المنطقه الغنيه بالمياه والتي كان بامكان
سكانها الوصول الى المياه العذبه من
الابار للحفاظ على الثروه السمكيه
اما الان فقد انعكس الوضع تماما
وتسبب ركود المياه والجفاف فيها الى
انتشار الامراض الفتاكه التي ساهمت في
انخفاض الانتاج السمكيه
جفاف المياه يعني زادت الامراض
الاسماك تمرضت يعني
فانتاجيت قلت شوف ان كانت الانهار شويه
ميه مرتفع ومجاري مثل ما نقول احنا نعبر
عليه يعني كان وصلنا مي عزب بالابار
مالتنا كان نقدر نستفاد من الماء
شوي شوي قام يصعد الكبريت عدنا بالماء
ماله البيض وهذا سببها لاكات
السبب الرئيسي ويعود الى انخفاض التدفقات
من ايران وتركيا والتي كانت تصدر حوالي
70% من نهرين دجله والفرات واصبح الجفاف
والعواصف الرمليه ودرجات الحراره العاليه
تشكل تهديدا وجودا لدى العراقيين بشكل
متزايد
فانتاج الاسماك في محافظه النجف قد بلغ
نحو الكيط من سنويا في عام 2018
وانخفض حاليا الى نحو 700 طن وفقا لمدير
الزراعه في النجف وهو الامر الذي ادى
بطبيعه الحال الى نقص الاسماك في السوق
وارتفاع اسعارها بشكل مبالغ وتوقف بعض
المزارعين عن العمل
وزاره المراه
يعني
احنا كنا 20 20 طن او 40 طن
صار ماكو ما يسدد حتى
سعر الاسماك اللي تجيبه فاحنا
بالله قلت من اقل الانتاج توقفنا عن العمل
وقد احتجت بغداد مرارا على هذه السدود
المشيد على نهري الفرات ودجله التي يعتمد
عليها العراق في تامين المياه كما فاق ما
ازمه شح المياه تدني كميه الامطار على مدى
السنوات الماضيه بسبب التغير المناخي
سلطان العربيه
مشاهدينا العود الى تصريحاتي ابنتي الشقيب
لابن شقيقته خامنئي للعربيه الذي يقول ان
سياسه عجزت عن احتواء كل الازمات يقول
ايضا ابن شقيقه المرشده الايراني النظام
الايراني ينتهي حقوق المراه منذ 40 عاما
وافراد العائله لا يستطيعون التعبير عن
ارائهم معتقدات النظام لا تسمحوا بتشكيل
حكومه معتدله في ايران
التي يقوم بها النظام الايراني
قتل بسبب معربته لان النظام
الايراني
مشاهدينا ننتقل الان الى اخبار الاقتصاد
شكرا يا احمد اهلا بكم مشاهدينا لنرق نظر
على تداولات اسواق المنطقه كما هي بالوقت
الحاضر من بعد مقام الفدراليه يوم امس كما
كان متوقعا برفع اسعار الفائده ب 50 نقطه
اساس من بعد اربع رفعات ب 75 نقطه اساس
بكل مره لحقت اليوم عدد من البنوك
الخليجيه خمسه من السته لاحقات بقرار
الفيدرالي البنك المركزي السعودي القطري
الاماراتي والبحريني منذ يوم امس مساء يوم
امس رفعوا اسعار الفائده العماني قبل قليل
صباح اليوم لاحقا ايضا بالفيدرالي ورفع
اسعار الفائده ب 50 نقطه اساس الكويت
دائما في يعني لا يرفع المركز الكويتي
مباشره بعد الفدراليه لانه الدينار
الكويتي ليس مربوط دايركت باج مع الدولار
ومربوط بسله من العملات بينهم العملات
الخليجيه الاخرى مربوطه مباشره بالدولار
ولذلك البنوك المركزيه الخليجيه الاخرى
بتلحق مباشره بخطوه عليه هذا سوق الاسهم
السعوديه اليوم على ثبات همم يعني كان في
بعض التذبذب بتفتح صباحا على بعض النزول
ارجع سجل شويه ارتفاع الان على ث ذكر ان
سوق السعودي يوم الاثنين سجل ادنى مستوى
منذ ابريل 21 بالتل يرتاد بجلسات الثلاثاء
والاربعاء سجل بعض الارتداد اليوم عم نشوف
سباته هذه الاسهم الاكثر ارتفاعا بالوقت
الحاضر في السوق السعوديه عجيب للالات
وركس
من ضمن القائمه لانه ممكن نظره على الاسهم
الاكثر تراجعا الرعايه المستقبليه بنك
البلاد لانها تركي مريم اللي عم تندمج مع
الدرع العربي دوائيه من الاسهم المتراجعه
هذه الاسهم الاكثر تداولا بالقيمه
امريكانا للمطاعم تتراجع اليوم من بعد
ثلاث جلسات من الارتفاع سعر
68 هلاله هي عملت ادراج مزدوج بابو ظبي
السعوديه اليوم
ولكن تداول عليه عاليه الراجحي ايضا على
تراجعوا معادن على تراجع بينما مرافق هذا
الادراج ايضا الوافد الجديد بالسوق
السعوديه على ارتفاع بالقطاع المصري في
الصوره ايجابيه ما عدا على الراجحي في
تراجعات البنوك عاده تستفيد من رفع
الفائده لانه بتمرر
يعني بشكل
العملاء المستديمين وبدها وقت لترفع على
الودائع على حتى تستحق الودائع القطاع
الطاقه ارامكو على ثبات بترو رابع مدراجعه
واخيرا نظره على قطاع المواد الاساسيه
سابك على ارتفاع بنصف النقطه المئويه اعود
القاكم في الاسواق العربيه بعد قليل بيكون
لدينا متسع من الوقت للحديث عن الاخبار
الاقتصاديه عوده اليك احمد الان الان
شكرا نادين في المغرب
والحزن بين جماهير المغرب التي اعتادت
الاحتفال باعداد الغفيره في مختلف بقاع
العالم خلال مسيره الفريق وعلى الرغم من
خساره الفريق امام الجماهير شهدت في ساحات
المغرب احتفالا لمنتخبهم الذي دخل التاريخ
بعد ما اصبح اول فريق افريقي يبلغ الدوره
قبل النهائي لكاس العالم لكره القدم
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الاخبار المونديال مع عبد الله درويش
حياكم الله مشاهدينا الى الموجز الرياضي
حمله الدفاع عن اللقب لمنتخب فرنسا تستمر
بعد فوزه على نظيره المغربي بهدفين دون رد
ليضرب موعدا كبيره مع الارجنتين في نهائي
كاس العالم الاحد المقبل على ملعب لوسيا
نجح المنتخب الفرنسي بتسجيل الهدف الاول
عند الدقيقه الخامسه عبر فيو هيرنانديز
اتمكن المنتخب المغربي من امتلاك الكره في
معظم اوقات
محاولا تسجيل هدف التعادل لكنه لم ينجح
بذلك حتى سجل المنتخب الفرنسي ثاني اهداف
في الدقيقه التاسعه والسبعين لتنتهي بذلك
مشاركه المنتخب التاريخيه في المونديال
افضل انجازا عربي وافريقيا بالوصول الى
نصف النهائي ومازال يملك فرصه الحصول على
المرتبه الثالثه
في مباراه تحديد المركزيه الثالث
واتجه وليد الرجراجي ولاعبوه الى الجماهير
ويتبادلات تحيه والتصفيق بعد الظهور
المشرف في هذه البطوله
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
قام الرئيس الفرنسي مانويل ماكرون بزياره
الى سوق واقف في الدوحه قبل ساعات من
مباراه بلاده امام المغرب في نصف نهائي
مونديال قطر قبل ان يتوجه الى الملعب
لمتابعه مجريات اللقاء
بدا منتخب كرواتيا استعداداته لمباراه
المركز الثالث التي ستقام السبت المقبل
وقام قائد المنتخب مودريتش ببعض التمارين
الخفيفه خلال التدريبات مع استمرار تزايد
التكهنات بشان مستقبله الدولي ولم يستطع
المدرب السابق غزلاتكو داليتش تاكيدا ما
اذا كان صانع الالعاب سيقرروا الاعتزال
بعد مباراه تحديد المركز الثالث وقال ان
العالم باسره سيبتقده في حال قرر الاعتزال
ميسي كان على الموعد امام مكروه سجل هدفا
وصنعه اخرا وهو من قاد الهجمه في الهدف
الثاني لزميله الفارس اعدنا الى اجواء 86
وتنتظر المباراه النهائيه عله يزيد بعض
الارقام
قبل مباراتك كرواتيا بالدوري النصف
النهائي رفرف قميصه عاليا في سماء مدينه
ميسي الى النهائي
ميسي كان في الموعد امام كرواتيا سجل هدفا
وصنع اخر وهو من قاد الهجمه في الهدف
الثاني لزميله البرنس
نجم باريس سان جيرمان وبهدفه في مرمى
كرواتيا تمكن من الانفرادي بصداره
الهدافين التاريخيين للارجنتين في
النهائيات باحد عشر هدفنا بعدما تقاسمها
خلال الايام الماضيه مع باتيستوتا صاحب ال
10 اهداف
صاحب الرقم القياسي كاكثر اللاعبين مشاركه
في نهائيات كاس العالم بعدما تقاسم الرقم
في مباراه كرواتيا مع الالماني لوثر
ماتيوس صاحب الخمس والعشرين مشاركه في
بطوله العالميه
الفينال كاميرا
السابقه والذي يلعب المونديال الخامس مع
التانجو والاخير في مسيرته الكرويه
ظهر هذه المره بشخصيه مخالفه عن مشاركته
السابقه داخل وخارج الملعب
لفت الانذار وجعل الارجنتينيين يتفائلون
اكثر باللقب الغائب عن خزائنهم منذ
مونديال مكسيكو 86 بعد محمد في وقت سابق
مسؤوليتك كل اخفاء
ما اشبه اجواء مونديال 86 الارجنتين
بقياده مارادونا ومونديال قطر الذي يسير
فيه رفاق ميسي بخطى ثابته نحو وضع النجمه
الثالثه على القميص الابيض والازرق
فهل ينجح ميسي في قياده الارجنتين لرفع
الكاس ام تستمر الخيبه لاربع سنوات مقبله
[موسيقى]
ماساه في عرض بحر الماش بغرق قارب للهجره
غير القانونيه في اجواء شديده البروده
اعادت الى الواجهه ملفا ساخنا يوتر
العلاقات بين بريطانيا وفرنسا منذ سنوات
وعود بريطانيا بمعالجه سريعه لمشكله
الهجره
تحول بحر المارش من طوق نجاه لالاف
المهاجرين الحالمين بالمستقبل افضل الى
مصيده موت تحول دون عبورهم بين عالم
الفقير واخر واحد بالفراص مره اخرى وقع في
فخ الموت زورق على متنه 40 مهاجرا يامرون
بالوصول الى اليابسه البريطانيه
انا سبونج بوب
اتفاقيات مع البانيا وفرنسا تطبيق صارم
لقوانين الهجره والنصوص تشريعيه صريحه
لاول مره
تعون فرنسا وبريطانيا على انقاذ ضحايا
الثوره لا يخفي الخلافه بين الطرفين على
قضيه المهاجرين وبغض النظر عن التنسيق
بريطانيا الى حل سريع لهذه المعضله بعد ان
شدد رئيس الوزراء ريش سوناك على ان
المهاجرين غير القانونيين يستغلون ما وصفه
بكرم بريطانيا
يقولولي
لا يمكنك البقاء
لكن مقابل وجهه النظر هذه يا عيب فريق على
لندن ما يصفه بالازدواجيه في التعامل مع
المهاجرين فطريق القادمين من اوكرانيا على
سبيل المثال سهله ومعبده اما الاقل حظا
وبخاصه اولئك المهاجرون من سوريا
وافغانستان وغيرهم فغالبا ما تغلق الابواب
الفرنسيه خلفهم والبريطانيه امامهم ولا
يبقى لهم سوى البحر وزوارق اشبه بتوابيت
عائمه
انس نماسي العربيه
اعرب المدير العام لمنظمه الصحه العالميه
تدرس دانون عن امله في ان لا تتسبب جيئحه
كورونا في اعلان حاله طوارئ صحيه عالميه
العام المقبل
من 10,000 شخصياتهم ولا يزال هذا الرقم
كبير جدا
من العام المقبل سنتمكن من القول ان
الفايروس كورونا لم يعد حاله طوارئ صحيه
عالميه
اوقف تويتر حساب الاستخدام بيانات الرحلات
الطيران المتاحه على نان لتتبع الطائرات
الخاصه لملكه تويتر الى الماسك ياتي هذا
الايقاف على الرغم من تعهد مالك منصه
الجديد بالابقاء عليه بسبب مبادئ حريه
التعبير ولم تعد تغريدات الحساب الذي تتبع
للذي تتبع بيانات رحله الطائره ماسك متاحه
يذكر ان الحساب كان لديه اكثر من 500
226,000 متابع حتى يوم الثلاثاء
وفي ختام هذه الساعه الاخباريه
قوت يونيفيل تفتح وتحقيقا بالتعاون مع
لبنان في مقتل جندي ايرلنديين بالرصاص قرب
بيروت
السلطات الايرانيه تحكم الاعدام على
متظاهره بتهمه صنع الزجاجات حارقه وكتابه
شعارات
[تصفيق]
برلمانات الاوروبيه تعلن دعم المحتجين
الايرانيين المعرضين للاعدام ومطالبات
بمعاقبه النظام
واشنطن تخطط لارسال معدات الكترونيه
متطوره لاوكرانيه
البريطانيه تقول ان رئيس الوزراء في
سوناتا يخطط لفرد قوانين المكافحه
الاضرابات
نهايه هذه نفس المشاهدنا كونوا فيها
[موسيقى]